welcome to dw news asia glad you could
join us
the united states has warned afghanistan
that the taliban could make rapid
territorial gains
if u.s led nato forces withdraw from the
country
by the 1st of may the warning is
contained in a letter from u.s secretary
of state anthony blinken
to afghanistan's president ashraf ghani
some 10
000 u.s led nato troops are due to pull
out from the country according to the
terms of an agreement
reached between the united states and
the taliban last year
the letter from blinken also proposes
urgent steps
towards achieving a permanent ceasefire
in the country
including a u.n backed meeting of
foreign ministers of regional nations
a meeting between the afghan government
and the taliban in turkey
and efforts to achieve a 90-day
reduction in violence
and joining me now from herat in western
afghanistan is correspondent ali latifi
ali has there been any reaction from the
afghan government to the proposals
from secretary blinken
the avalon government hasn't said
anything specific yet
in response to the proposal
and there are reports that basically the
government has
basically reduced their meeting loads
today and
it's sending a signal that basically
they're trying to figure out
what to do with this message and
how to go forward because a lot of the
things that
they had hoped for with the biden
administration this letter
makes very clear isn't happening so my
khali zod is saying
they aren't trapping the process
entirely and in fact
the letter says that you know a decision
needs to be reached very quickly
some kind of a settlement some kind of a
peace agreement
so any sort of uh hope for a change in
course seems to have gone out the window
at this point
now the letter also talks about uh
developing a consensus
on power sharing with the taliban is
that a reality that the afghan
government
needs to accept
at this point it seems that way because
if the us
is in charge of this deal and if they
are
uh calling in the u.n and if they are
calling in neighboring nations
you know this kind of an agreement this
kind of a suggestion doesn't come out of
nowhere
there had to have been some forethought
ahead of time the fact that they're
calling in
all of these representatives from
neighboring nations the fact that
they're
uh asking for the u.n to take such a big
role
it seems as if you know in a lot of ways
this has already been decided
now the question is will the government
accept it and just as importantly
will the taliban accept that they've
sent out messages recently saying that
they don't want to be part of any kind
of interim government
obviously the avalon government has been
very adamant against the
interim government the president has
said you know he will die before he sees
an interim government
um but the letter is very strongly
worded
so the question is how will both sides
react to
such uh you know strong strong things
coming from the united states now ali
we've talked about this many times
before but anthony blinken has still not
made it clear
if u.s troops are staying or leaving
this is a huge issue for the avalon
government and for the people
if you look at some of the early drafts
of that letter that were leaked
there were elements that said that they
were still considering
uh keeping withdrawing all of their
troops by may first
but at the end of it as you said you
know this is the thing that the
government wants a clear answer
that the people want a clear answer to
this is sort of giving a road map for
some kind of a pea settlement but it's
not giving the final
most important answer which is what's
going to happen after may 1st
um and so i think again this may be
the u.s pulling some kind of leverage
reminding them that
you know as much as we've decided sort
of
a path going forward for you our troops
are still up for contention
thank you very much for that
you